[Music]
good morning from camera camp Jenna and
I are in Monterey California right now
Monterey is so beautiful I was only here
once before this is my second time and
we're here for something very very fun
Sonne invited a bunch of well pretty
much the most incredible photographers
around the world here to what we're
calling camera camp but it's actually
called condo they have a ton of
activities planned for everyone there's
a few other youtubers here too so we're
kind of like the odd people out because
I mean I'm an OK photographer but really
what I focus mostly on is this video
John has already taken pictures are you
taking picture of video right now we're
heading to breakfast
this is where Jenna shines okay on the
menu are all of our favorite things
oh my gosh - give me it for me
the boyfriend my breakfast is popping
and Jenna got four to go cups I made a
mistake I thought the one was coffee it
was water so I have a cup of hot water
and creamer I don't want to talk about
it
[Music]
do you know how many sasquatches we
could find with that I'm so excited I
still ate it I was like I wonder if this
door will have a Gerber Mattei and guess
what if they do any of Google's online
we are on the vlogger bus and the
difference between live loggers and the
photographer's here is who knows but you
can squat up in my lungs we have these
microphones on top of our cameras
because they're so building how you can
tell a vlogger between a photographer I
think these massive microphones a lot
louder oh well I wanted to go around and
do introductions of everybody's channel
but Brett already did it so is that
weird if we do it again
my name is Bhavik and my channel is
called iPhone it is like Nintendo with
an iPhone iPhone the first video that I
saw of his I don't wanna bring it up
it's kind of a sore subject
sorry GoPro but it was his karma video
and then I've been a huge fan ever since
cuz we both learned a lot big fans on
the Karma the GoPro Karma
the worst job I have ever flown
[Music]
hi I'm sure you probably have seen me
observe your videos I'm having fun you
want me to handle this for you
okay okay hi I'm Jason I make videos on
sony alpha specifically on other cameras
and lenses and teach people tips and
tricks and yeah people know me as mondo
bytes I do tech videos I do a lot of
filmmaking stuff how to color grade
pretty much anything I'm just interested
in filming but mostly tech and anything
relating to film well I mean that would
be why we're all here you know hey Craig
Adams xkc nice tie ripoff artist yeah I
just do travel stuff so my name is Steve
Ronan and basically I'm an urban
exploration photographer and I kind of
flog that lifestyle on my youtube
channel so go check it out we'll
continue introductions after Donuts to
be honest I just want to look at the
donuts I don't I do want to eat
[Music]
don't try that at home I'm gonna close
they're older how I don't know oh you're
fine yeah like blossom phobic have you
guys locker
[Music]
we're inside the aquarium and I did in
terms of everybody you're the only one
that I haven't introduced yet oh I was
so zoned out thinking about life really
quick
my name's Josh from exploring with Josh
I do abandon places around the world and
I just travel and make love I actually
checked off your channel before we go
here yeah cuz they there was like an
email like a ruse here no and I know
that it was really great so I yeah I
won't we'll have to do some random stuff
yeah where are you based out of I live
quad based in Boston but I'm here for
the whole month
what LA yeah dude this is very meant to
do whatever we can do we're gonna do
some cool stuff you like the honey
jumping cream I love hiking we should do
that Haley yeah
[Music]
so sea bass is my favorite fish to eat
and now I don't think I'm ever gonna be
able to eat it again because now I've
looked him in the eye and he looks back
[Music]
[Applause]
China has been trying to touch it touch
it just grab it
you're gonna touch it or so right now it
is a sea otter eating time so we're
gonna see if we can see them I'm gonna
try to go upstairs and see now our three
sea otters are doing what we call
positive reinforcement training that
means we ask them to do something and
then when they do that we reinforce it
or thank them for doing the behavior and
hope they do it again by doing something
positive so in this case the pets food
we are in the deep ocean now
so what look how cool
[Music]
that I've ever seen this entire little
aquarium tank is full of jellyfish I
thought the sterling fish over there
were cool when there was like two of
them there's only like 40 15 I don't
know
[Music]
[Applause]
we've seen so many cool things with
aquarium Annelle at the store and I want
to get Maddie a toy and I'm thinking
that he probably would really love this
little otter loves his piggy puppet this
actually looks like him oh my goodness
I think this offers beans in it though
this seems like a little finger puppet
puppet mini baby penguin super cute I
think Maddie will like it those of you
guys who don't know Maddie is my dog
this is Nicole we had so much fun of the
aquarium this was so awesome
did you like it this was the coolest
thing ever the jellyfish favorite thing
I've ever seen it was incredible I mean
they were just so slow-moving it was
almost like it was slow-mo but it wasn't
it was real no I'm I like jellyfish
[Music]
back here at the resort and now guess
what if time for lunch so basically we
ate went to the aquarium now we're going
to eat again human feeding time here
maybe whoa wait that didn't sound good
hello welcome to my meal so we have an
incredible it's on wheat bread now our
practical look like they did a little
rebrand Sun Chips I'm not done apple
slices and the rest of the adults we all
have salads the calories is so much so
1,500 okay I'm testing out this lens now
I'm super excited about this one this is
a wide-angle lens and we're heading to
it class right now
it's called unlock L so if you have any
questions about your camera you can ask
them and they will answer them I'm
preparing my questions mentally but this
lens is pretty cool what's it look like
wide-angle nice my anger Wow pretty eyes
thing do you like it not like it this is
the one I'm borrowing from the rental
shine doesn't up the little guy on there
okay I brought the big boy
[Music]
[Applause]
we just left our first class and now
we're heading over they have these photo
sets where you could take pictures of
things and they also have one that is
puppies and kitties so guess what we're
going poppy and kitty Cosette I didn't
know there was like real kids yeah Mindy
we just - uh-huh
she is beta site I'm out of here
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
that you've been the highlight of my day
yes there are incredible cameras and so
many lenses and amazing people here but
Mindy was the sweetest little dog and
well her adopted brother Ted please
Weasley's if anybody wins Ted who happen
to live near Monterey California go get
Ted go get Mindy and see what other dogs
they have available I love it then to
ride bikes none of our other friends
have helmets but I think I'm gonna be
safe and I'm gonna wear one because you
should always wear a helmet and I don't
trust myself yeah I think you guys need
them oh wow yeah where are we
Monterey California baby off we go
bike squad Rowland goodness gracious
there we go
[Music]
okay guys we've made a first off it's
only been four minutes and I think I'm
dying
Wow we need it every block we're gonna
stop like walking riding a bike is not
I'm good at just wanted though
we're doing a good job
[Music]
the show we're all trying to get a pig
fortunately we have to turn around
because we have a meeting at 3:00 but
these guys are going what 17 - 17 miles
it's gonna be a great 17 miles we're all
energetic we're all ready and what is at
the end of 17 miles I don't know okay
I'm gonna steal the clip from its video
and then you can go watch the rest of it
to find out where it 17 miles I think I
didn't vlog it today I'm the only one I
know i vlog all yesterday that i'll be
stealing a clip from breaths then you
can see the rest of the video on his
channel so subscribe you go get it or
what Josh okay his channel is pretty fun
everybody's channel is fun can't vlog
and ride a bike so my legs hurt already
bike ride again something
[Music]
down except turn here's their own
earnest I've been talking about it
non-stop since I saw it at CES so hold
the trigger here yeah hold the trigger
till your horizontal okay now double tap
all right now just pan right there you
guys are gonna see this and so many vlog
as we've looking you please stop it's
been non-stop it suits you it's really
nice
no I mean if you ever want to like start
working with autofocus I'm treating you
a little bit as you're walking I can
just tap as you move and change what's
in focus so yeah really really pretty
that's really good idea because I
actually have all the auto focus turned
off on the touchscreen because I'm
always accidentally hitting it but this
is a really good use case for it is it
steady but my arms are hurting okay this
is me holding it with one arm hello oh
yeah that's great
how are we ever gonna pack all this
stuff because we've we have so much more
stuff than we came with today
wait you're not laying the right thing
if they're like the end of the bag the
edges of the bag
no but it's gonna wait no work this is
gonna leave
look at the nice fire I made that
you believe in Gemma so we were packing
and we were just joking oh we're never
gonna win anything that's crazy it's not
gonna happen
Channel just won an a 7r3 we heard it
over the loudspeaker and then all of our
vlog squad friends so we're gonna run
down and block squad man if we have that
romanesque this would be so steady there
it is the best possible thing that I
will ever win so I'd like to thank Sony
prepare a speech but I'm very thankful
you believe it Chad no I can't believe
you also just ran into them too
that's pretty crazy we were on our way
down well congratulations
I'm surrounded ok ok we'll go back up
now ok now they can go back and be warm
[Music]
you